hey what is up guys I'm cabby HD here
let's check these out this is a
recommendation for the holiday season in
the audio department so you might
remember that video I did on open-back
headphones a couple of weeks ago had a
bunch of different pairs of headphones
in that video but this is an actual
recommendation and a good place to start
these are the great oh SR ad e part of
the great o prestige series and overall
part of a pretty underrated brand plenty
of people haven't even heard of grado
but they are quality so with these you
can actually think of them as an
evolution of the SR ATI that actually
reviewed about three years ago they had
this old-school look looks like
something that should have a tape player
on the other end of it not the prettiest
thing in the world to some but more of a
timeless classic to others the cable is
great it's a thick four-foot straight
cable that splits to connect to both
ears and the build of the headphones
themselves is really simple you can tell
where they saved money on the build and
put that in the audio quality so a thin
wire on the top with this strip of
leather to rest on top of your head no
real cushion here but then again they
are pretty lightweight so they're
comfortable without a huge cushion and
the foam pads on the headphones
themselves are removable and I checked
on Amazon there are third-party foam
pads that you can buy or even leather
ones that are softer or thicker or even
sound different but these stock foam
ones are on ears so they just rest on
your ear and sound good and like I said
this is a great first pair of open-back
headphones for all the reasons described
in that explained video this soundstage
is wide the sound is detailed and more
natural and actually think a tiny bit
more balanced than those SR 80 is the
sound leaked actually not as bad as I
remember so they're not like mini
speakers on your head or anything but if
someone's sitting near you they'll
definitely be able to hear where you're
listening to and also since they're open
back not only does the sound get out but
sound also gets in so the ambient sound
of your environment will play a factor
in your music or whatever you're
listening to but yeah overall everything
sounds really punchy and rich and that
all makes these a great intro a great
first pair of open-back headphones
especially thanks to the price these are
all over the internet at sub $100 and
it's worth noting that these also have a
slightly less expensive little brother
called the SR 60 II you're only about 20
bucks less than the SRA de so not really
a whole lot of reason to get them for
big savings or anything but they make
for an even more budget-friendly option
I'll link both of them below so either
way this hand-built pair of headphones
is a great
I and a pretty easy choice for a gift
for someone who's into audio or a future
audio file in your life or even yourself
so that's been it thanks for watching
this quick review if you pick them up to
free let me know what you think of them
on Twitter or in the comments section
below and I'll talk to you guys in the
next one peace